et bien bonjour ça veut sa petite dose
de frissons vous arrêtez de me demander
tous les jours des serait d'horreur
d'accord si vous continuez je fais la
grève des serait d'horreur je rigole pas
un aujourd'hui trois histoires vraiment
bien je suis très heureux des histoires
d'aujourd'hui surtout qu'il y en a une
qu'on a trouvé sur le let's not mink
donc leur ai dit où des gens raconte des
expériences un peu flippante donc
l'histoire que je raconte dans cette
vidéo la fr et oui je mettrais bien une
description ci voulait raconter des
histoires dessus qui me sont arrivées
n'hésitez pas c'est l'endroit pourrait
donc aujourd'hui pour la première fois
on raconte une histoire de solid snake
[ __ ] fr et elle est incroyable mais
d'abord on commence avec l'histoire de
tomic qui lui n'est pas français
pourquoi juste avant l'histoire de tommy
découvrez d'abord l'incroyable histoire
sponsorisés de clarence joyeux
anniversaire clarence x ptdr c'est quoi
ce prénom tekki michael alias michael le
beau gosse ça mais je t'ai jamais
invités
j'ai ramené des macbook pro des iphone
12 pro et des airpod 2 pour tout le
monde
ok tu peux rester beau gosse je peux
avoir l'iphone oui pour ça il te suffit
de cliquer sur mon lien en descriptions
ya quoi sur ce lien lors du mobile où
est-ce qu'il a chopé la télécommande
lors du mobile est un jeu de guerre et
de stratégie mobile gratuit le but est
de développer au royaume ton armée
modifier la formation des troupes
recruter choisir les meilleurs héros et
créer des alliances pour imposer dans un
monde médiéval fantastique rempli de
magie et de créatures maléfiques et pour
les cadeaux en plus en ce moment il y à
une collab avec les chevaliers du
zodiaque le héros cia est offert au
téléchargement
tu n'as pas répondu à ma question
j'allais y venir clavicule ne t'en fais
pas non ça se prononce clarence je m'en
tape
à chaque fois que ton château augmente
de niveau tourner la roue de la fortune
pour tenter ta chance tu tomberas
peut-être sur un des grands prix ou de
cadeaux en jeu trop cool tu es le
meilleur michael burgos bon maintenant
on peut revenir à mon anniversaire s'il
vous plaît merkel
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez gagner des
cadeaux
en téléchargeant lors du mobile grâce à
ton lien en description c'est bon on
sait que pourraient leur demander de me
souhaiter mon anniversaire plus tôt ah
oui pardon souhaitez tous un bon
anniversaire à clavicule à l'essai châu
dôc me travaille dans une station
service minable vous savez aux états
unis il ya énormément de stations
service et en a beaucoup qui sont
vraiment des tout petits trucs un peu
creepy minuscule pas très bien entretenu
et bientôt mis lui il travaille dans
l'une de ses stations service dont qu'il
est seul il est assis sur un tabouret
derrière le comptoir et ils attendent
des clients viennent pour payer leur
plein et précise qu autour de sa station
service si on a deux autres qui sont
beaucoup plus moderne et que donc les
clients se font plus en plus rare à la
sienne puisqu'il préfère aller dans les
trucs beaucoup plus de 9
il explique carrément que son taf c'est
plus de venus nettoyer essayer
d'entretenir commis peu cet endroit qui
est vraiment crasseux et pas vraiment
accueillir des clients à la chaîne qui
payent leur plein d'essence bref ce jour
là et les 00h30 tommy travail de nuit
est il à 6h30 à tuer il est assis sur
son tabouret derrière le comptoir il est
en train de lire un livre et il fait
tout ce qu'il peut pour pas regarder
l'horloge parce que le temps passe très
lentement soudainement du coin de l'oeil
et voit un break s'approcher de l'une
des pompes deux hommes en sortent et se
rendent à l'intérieur de la petite
boutique de tomi l'un des deux est
plutôt âgée porte une veste en cuir et
l'autre par contre est beaucoup plus
jeune il a à peu près l'âge de tommy est
hilare manteau carhartt et des bottes de
travail bref comme il est décrit comme
des gars de la campagne rien
d'inquiétant il leur dit bonjour et leur
demande en quoi il peut les aider
et puis le plus jeune des deux hommes
lui dit vous savez que vous êtes
surveillés
tommy comprend pas pourquoi elle lui dit
ça et le jeune homme pointe du doigt
quelque chose à l'extérieur
dehors il y a une silhouette sont d'un
homme qui se tient debout près d'un
réverbère
le plus âgé des deux hommes expliquent
atomique qui sont passés devant la
station service il ya quarante-cinq
minutes et qu'ils ont failli écraser un
mec qui se tenait au milieu de la route
et ce mec c'est apparemment le games
mobile qui se trouve pas loin du
réverbère depuis des dizaines de minutes
l'homme âgé explique qu'ils ont
peut-être pensé que le mec était drogué
ou qu'ils avaient de mauvaises
intentions et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
décidé de faire demi tour et de venir
voir à la station-service si tout allait
bien pendant que les trois hommes
discutent l'inconnu se tient toujours
debout immobile dehors mais tommy il
arrive à distinguer le fait que le gars
a l'air de parler tout seul il voit sa
mâchoire bouger comme si le mec se
parlaient à lui même et c'est là qu'il
va prendre les choses en main il va
demander aux deux hommes de verrouiller
la porte d'entrée du magasin qui
constitue sa seule défense et il va leur
demander d'attendre avec lui à
l'intérieur du magasin le temps qu'il
appelle la police et c'est là qu'ils se
posent une question terrible
il se dit mais est-ce que les deux mecs
qui sont maintenant enfermée avec moi
dans mon magasin sont vraiment là pour
m'aider
est ce que ces deux gars ne serai pas
complice du troisième cas près du
réverbère
quoi qu'il en soit il peut rien faire il
est surveillé du coin de l'oeil il prend
son portable
il appelle la police et la police répond
et ludique elle sera sur les lieux d'ici
dix minutes
tommy est grandement rassuré il
raccroche il explique aux deux hommes
que la police arrive et qui peuvent donc
circuler il les remercie encore une fois
de l'avoir prévenu les deux gars sortent
de la boutique font quelques mètres et
puis s'arrête
et ils lui disent verrouille la porte il
arrive tommy se précipite vers la porte
d'entrée il a verrouillé à double tour
et en regardant à travers la vitre ils
voient effectivement la silhouette qui
était jusque là immobile sprinter vers
le magasin tommy hill accroupis derrière
le comptoir il voit plus ce qui se passe
mais il entend et ce qu'il entend pour
la première fois c'est la voie du
troisième inconnue est cet inconnu une
demande aux deux autres où est allé le
garçon l'homme âgé lui répond et c'est
de faire gagner du temps à tommy lui dit
écoute il est allé dans la salle de bain
il revient immédiatement l'inconnu se
précipitent de l'autre côté du bâtiment
et de l'autre côté du bâtiment il ya une
porte qui mène à la salle de bains tommy
hill se pose plein de questions est ce
que ce mec était déjà venu en repérage
avant ce soir
est-ce qu'il est venu dans ses
stations-service au hasard ou est-ce
qu'il a choisi ses stations service
parce qu'il m'a vu à la caisse est ce
qu'il est vraiment sous drogue oui ce
qu'il est juste purement malveillants et
heureusement pour lui la police a fait
extrêmement ville puisque à ce moment-là
à un suv arrive et trois policiers
descendent immédiatement du véhicule ils
font le tour du bâtiment malheureusement
ils tombent sur personne
l'inconnu a disparu probablement quand
il a entendu les gyrophares tommy prend
le temps d'aller remercier les deux
inconnus ans qu'il a douté pendant de
longues minutes avant de comprendre
c'était vraiment de son côté et il a
jamais su qui était ce mec est pourquoi
ils en avaient après lui est ce que
c'était un gars de son entourage est ce
que c'était gratos c'est ce qu'il a
juste pas de chance paris n'en sais rien
en revanche il a demandé à son boss
d'installer des caméras de sécurité vers
l'extérieur et ça n'a pas été fait alors
à tous les frérots kibo seul dans des
boutiques ou qui bosse de nuit et tout
courage grosse force je serai en panique
c'est l'heure de la deuxième histoire
c'est l'histoire de anaïs notre
française qu'a vécu un truc terrible
quand elle était jeune anaïs explique
que c'est maintenant une femme elle
vient d'avoir 19 ans et qu'au moment des
faits elle en avait 15 presque 16
elle entre en seconde au lycée donc
grande année et aussi elle ouvre son
compte twitter elle précise que son nom
d'utilisateur elle ne l'a donné à
personne
la photo du compte ce n'est pas une
photo d'elle c'est une image qu'elle
aime bien avatar quelconque
elle est donc anonyme elle explique
qu'elle n'a jamais eu beaucoup de
followers elle est monté à 30 follower
max et qu'elle suivait pas beaucoup de
gens elle sur twitter enfin c'est
vraiment pas une applique à l'ouvré
souvent pour faire des trucs à son
foutais un peu
mais un soir d'octobre elle reçoit un
message privé chelou dans ce message
c'est un mec qui se présente qui
s'appelle paul k 17 ans et qui lui
demande si elle habite bien sûr anthony
parce qu'il vient d'y emménager et qu'il
aimerait bien se faire des amis avant
son premier jour de lycées immédiatement
anaïs et les méga méfiante elle se dit
attends comment il sait que j'habitais
anthony c'est marqué nulle part sur mon
profil
elle réfléchit et puis elle se souvient
qu'elle a fait un tweet qui parlait des
bus d'anthony et donc elle en conclut
que paul a probablement taper anthony
dans la barre de recherche twitter et
qu'il est tombé sur son tweet et c'est
comme ça qu'il est tombé sur elle anaïs
elle a 15 ans et vous savez très bien
quand on a 15 ans on est vraiment en
train de se construire fort quand on
rentre au lycée et elle c'est une
période qui est un peu compliqué là pas
trop d'amis etc
et comme paul a été polie et sympa bah
lui répond à lui répond donc que oui
elle habite bien anthony qu'elle est
bien au lycée là bas et les deux ont des
discussions de jeunes ils vont parler de
l'école de la bouffe de la cantine des
profs sûr qu'il faut pas tomber parce
qu'ils sont pas cool dre vraiment une
discussion classique de lycéens mais un
peu plus tard dans la soirée paul dans
cette discussion un peu classique de
lycéens il intercale des trucs un peu
moins classiques par exemple lui demande
si elle habite loin du lycée
si elle a beaucoup de frères et soeurs
si elle est souvent opaque chez elles
des questions que tu poses patronat
rarement quand tu tchatche avec
quelqu'un du lycée hamhuis heureusement
elle s'en rend compte et elle ne répond
tout simplement pas aux questions
bizarres de paul et voyant que anaïs ne
répond pas à ces questions là paul
évidemment il passe à autre chose et il
arrête de lui demander d'être déplacés
les deux vont ensuite discuté pendant
deux ou trois semaines
et évidemment quand à 15 ans et que tu
parles pour la première fois un mec ou
une meuf pendant deux ou trois semaines
quotidiennement plusieurs heures par
jour et ben tu développes des sentiments
anaïs tombe peu à peu amoureuse de
pommes elle a très peu d'amis personne
ne lui a jamais trop à porter
d'attention personnes a été gentil
avec elle elle explique d'ailleurs
qu'elle a subi beaucoup de harcèlement
et que donc à cette époque là il
suffisait d'être un petit peu sympa avec
elle pour qu'instantanément tu soit son
meilleur ami voire plus
anaïs fait de plus en plus confiance à
paul et baissent peu à peu sa garde et
juste avant la rentrée des vacances de
la toussaint
paul lui annonce la nouvelle y débarque
enfin dans son lycée anaïs est trop
heureuse elle lui donne une heure midi
et un lieu la cour de récré paul lui
répond qu'il est trop content et qu'il a
hâte mais qu' ils aimeraient l'avoir
sanquer plein de monde autour il
explique qu'il a peur de ne pas la
reconnaître et qui veut pas passer sa
récréation à la chercher perdre du temps
à nice compatit elle change donc
l'endroit du rendez-vous qui est
maintenant les toilettes du troisième
étage de l'école le lendemain matin à
nice se prépare elle se fait belle comme
jamais ça y est c'est le jour j c'est la
première fois qu'elle va rencontrer paul
elle compte les minutes la récréation
arrive elle court aux toilettes du
troisième étage et après quelques
minutes un homme arrive et cet homme
c'est bien paul c'est bel et bien la
photo du compte twitter à qui elle parle
depuis des semaines
mais quand même il fait un peu plus
vieux que 17 ans elle lui donne plutôt
vain que 17 ils s'entendent super bien
il ya une bête d'alchimie épaules
il propose anaïs de l'emmener manger au
kebab anaïs refuse pas parce qu'elle a
peur mais parce qu'elle n'a pas d'argent
sur elle et qu'elle a un principe c'est
qu'elle refuse tout le temps qu on
l'invite quelque part voilà l'air déçu
évidemment mais il lui propose à la
place de la tente devant le lycée à la
sortie des cours et de la raccompagner
chez elle ce qui quand tu es au lycée
honnêtement ce fait les bg ils font ça
en veut anaïs lui explique qu'elle rende
chez elle en bus et que donc s'il veut
il peut la raccompagner jusqu'à l'arrêt
de bus et ça va être le début d'une
routine qui va se mettre en place ou
tous les jours il va accompagner à nice
à la sortie des cours jusqu'à l'arrêt de
bus ça va durer des semaines des
semaines au cours desquelles anaïs elle
va quand même noter un truc un peu
bizarre c'est que elle croise jamais
paul dans le lycée bon rien de mes gars
alarmant elle met ça sur le fait que son
établissement il est méga grand il ya
1500 élèves et qu'il suffit que leurs
deux emplois du temps ne coïncident pas
pour qu'ils se croisent jamais on né le
14 décembre c'est un jeudi au cours
d'une discussion analyse se plaint à
paul de passer la soirée seul parce que
son père est en voyage pour le travail
son frère fait que de sortir chez des
amis sa soeur était en voyage scolaire
et sa mère travail ce jour là jusqu'à
très tard il ya vraiment une sorte d'
alignement des astres ce jour-là pour
qu'anaïs soit seule chez elle alors ayez
en tête qu'au moment où haïti ça à paul
il se parle depuis des mois c'est plus
un inconnu paul là c'est vraiment un
gars extrêmement proche d' analyse c'est
un vrai flirt un vrai cross
bref à l'issue de cette discussion anaïs
retourne en cours et en fin d'après midi
à la sortie des cours paul vient la
chercher et la compagne jusqu'à
l'arrivée
comme tous les jours depuis des mois
elle monte dans le bus elle met des
écouteurs à lui faire un signe de la
main
le bus par deux arrêts plus tard à nice
descend donc du bus et en descendant du
bus elle a un feeling bizarre elle à ce
fameux truc désagréable dans l'estomac
quand t'es pas bien quand on instinct te
dis attention
anaïs mais on pose sa musique mais elle
garde ses écouteurs pour faire genre
qu'elle entend rien de ce qui se passe
autour d'elle et c'est ce move qui lui a
probablement sauvé la vie elle quitte la
grande avenue pour s'engouffrer dans le
quartier pavillonnaire dans lequel elle
habite et pendant qu'elle marche
elle entend quelques mètres derrière
elle des bruits par anaïs mais
discrètement à la main dans sa poche
pour attraper les clés de chez elle elle
arrive devant chez elle elle met la clé
dans la serrure
elle ouvre à toute vitesse et l
désactive la la ce qui montre qu'elle
est bel et bien seule chez elle
à partir de là à les soulager et elle
s'assoit dos à la porte d'entrée
elle se lève elle regarde à travers la
vitre et sur la route devant sa maison
ya paul paul la regarde dans les yeux
d'un air malsain c'est plus le gars
mignon et gentilles qu'il était dans ses
discussions avec les précédents - les
deux se regardent et anaïs elle est en
full angoisse parce que elle sait que
paul est au courant qu'elle est seule
chez elle paralysée par la peur anaïs
reprend contrôle de son corps et elle
court dans sa cuisine pour attraper un
couteau elle retourne devant sa porte
d'entrée épauler maintenant juste de
l'autre côté en train de bourriner la
porte
anaïs fonce vers la porte d'entrée et la
plaque pour être sûr que le verrou ne
saute pas sous les coups de poing et au
même moment le voisin d'anaïs se gare
sur le trottoir et en voyant sa pole
pense que c'est la merde à nice 40
plutôt prévu et il part en courant
pendant deux heures
anaïs attend chez elle seule dans le
noir couteau dans la main et téléphone
dans l'autre et lorsqu'elle entend la
voiture de sa mère arrivée elle part en
courant dans sa chambre et elle fait
mine de rien à nice elle est tellement
traumatisée elle a tellement honte de ce
qui vient d'arriver alors qu'elle a
aucune raison d'avoir honte c'est juste
quelqu'un qui a abusé d'elle qui a été
manipulateur qui a été patient quelqu'un
qui rentrait dans son cerveau
d'adolescentes fragile mais comme
souvent dans ce genre d'histoire est la
honte et donc elle en parle à personne
les jours suivants sur twitter paul la
harcèle de messages et la menace et
l'insulté
à tel point qu'à nice le bloc et
supprime la conversation mais rapidement
elle est suivie par des comptes twitter
qui viennent d'être créées dont le nom
d'utilisateur est une suite de chiffres
suivi de la lettre p évidemment bol et
derrière ses comptes et à chaque fois
qu'elle en blocs à elle est suivie par
un nouveau qui le renvoie les mains
message au total anaïs va bloquer une
cinquantaine de ses comptes
mais comme ça continue elle va carrément
supprimé son compte twitter elle s'est
aussi renseigné auprès des autres élèves
de la classe de paul qui lui ont dit
n'avoir tout simplement jamais entendu
parler d'un paul vous avez compris en
fait paul il n'était pas du tout lycéen
il n'a jamais été dans ce lycée juste il
arrivait à rentrer dans le lycée le midi
pour le rendez vous devant les toilettes
et le soir il venait devant le lycée
pour l'accompagner jusqu'à l'arrêt bus
mais c'était pas un lycéen en fait bref
tous les doutes d'anaïs se confirme et
elle décide de ne pas porter plainte
en premier lieu parce qu'au moment des
faits elle est mineure et que donc si
elle va porter plainte elle doit en
parler à ses parents et elle n'a pas
envie d'en parler à ses parents et aussi
elle veut pas porter plainte parce
qu'elle n'a aucune preuve étant donné
qu'elle a supprimé son compte twitter
c'est des trucs arrive beaucoup plus
souvent qu'on le pense le fait d'être
abordée par des inconnus malveillants
sur internet alors elle dit il faut pas
devenir parano mais il faut avoir ça en
tête et rester prudent il ya des signes
qui ne trompent pas troisième histoire à
nos réalités longue la deuxième la
troisième histoire c'est celle de magali
elle a lieu aux états unis ça s'est
passé deux ans avant qu elle la raconte
à l'époque elle travaillait dans un
hôtel elle travaillait de nuit comme
pour tommy à la station service et quand
il travaillait nuit elle était seule
c'est à dire elle était à la réception
et avait personne d'autre dans l'hôtel
que l et les clients qui dans au moment
des faits anaïs est presque à la fin de
son service et ce soir là il s'est pas
passé grand chose
elle a juste enregistré un groupe de
gens qui faisaient un séminaire c'est
tout en regardant au loin magali voix
sur le parking d'une camionnette arrivé
et ce gars est un gars sort de la
voiture et il est couvert de saleté
magali elle s'en fout un peu elle a
l'habitude d'accueillir des clients qui
sont des gars qui font des travaux
manuels qui sont des ouvriers etc
généralement ils viennent après une
grosse journée travail donc c'est très
fréquent que des gars soient hyper taché
est pas propre quand il arrive à l'hôtel
l'inconnu arrive à l'accueil une demande
une chambre magali prend ces infos pour
l'enregistrer il s'appelle michael
elle lui demande sa plaque
d'immatriculation pour enregistrer le
véhicule puisse qui stationnent sur le
parking de l'hôtel et mickaël refuse et
demande une chambre au deuxième étage
près de l'escalier de secours pour
pouvoir s'y rendent et fumer des clopes
quand il en a envie bon rien d'anormal
magali procède au paiement et lui donne
la clé de sa chance mais qu'elle prend
l'escalier avec ses sacs et quelques
minutes plus tard il est de retour à la
réception et l'accuse magali lui avoir
donné une clé qui ne fonctionne pas
classique il a dû mettre la carte dans
sa poche près de son téléphone ou de ses
clés c'est la démagnétisée bref la
clasico magali magnétise donc une
seconde carte sauf que cette fois il
accompagne au deuxième étage jusqu'à sa
chambre pour lui ouvrir lui montrer que
ça marche bien elle redescend à la
réception et contrairement à la station
service de tommy
l'hôtel est très bien équipée en caméra
et en regardant le retour caméra du
parking elle se rend compte que la
camionnette de michael n'est plus sur le
parking sauf qu'elle vient d'accompagner
michael dans sa chambre c'est impossible
qu'ils soient descendus et qu'il ait
bougé la camionnette sans qu'elle le
voit 20 minutes passent au cours
desquelles il se passe rien d'anormal eu
michael traverse de nouveau le hall
principal et se rend à l'extérieur sur
le parking elles le voient s'allumer une
clope
rien d'anormal et puis michael revient
dans l'hôtel en courant cigarette à la
bouche donc magali lui dit si tu veux
fumer c'est dehors dans l'hôtel c'est
interdit michael jette sa clope par
terre les cras et s'assoit dans le
canapé de la réception devant la télé
magali comprend que le mec est chelou
et en plus ils regardent très
fréquemment vers l'entrée principale du
hall il est agité il a l'air un peu
paranoïaque et des fois ils se parlent
un peu à lui même ça va durer 30 minutes
30 minutes à l'issue desquelles magali
décide d'aller voir michael et de lui
dire écoute et vous n'avez pas le droit
de rester dans le hall à ces temps là
donc s'il vous plaît remonter dans votre
chambre
ce qui est écoutez moi bien un pur
mensonge il a totalement le droit d'être
là et de regarder la télé mais elle est
très méfiante parce que le mec est
vraiment chaud michael monte au deuxième
étage et avant de rentrer dans sa
chambre et redescend voir magali et lui
dit qu'il a oublié où se trouve sa
chambre et qu'il a besoin qu'elle le lui
montre et elle lui réexplique où je
trouve sa chambre à savoir au deuxième
étage à gauche
mais qu'at elle remonte les escaliers et
cette fois il trouve sa chambre et
claque la porte
dix minutes plus tard il redescend voir
magali et cette fois ils l'accusent
d'avoir volé son téléphone portable
anaïs comprend qu'elle est en danger
elle met un tournevis dans sa poche et
elle se rend au niveau des canapés sur
lesquels il a passé 30 minutes pour
fouiller entre les coussins voir si son
téléphone aurait pas glissé de sa poche
surprise elle tombe pas sur son
téléphone mais sur sa carte de crédit
elle lui donne et mickaël évidemment
l'accusent d'avoir volé sa carte de
crédit
là c'en est trop pour magali elle lui
dit écoutez si vous continuez de
m'accuser de vous voler des trucs c'est
simple j'appelle la police et on règle
ça y'a pas de soucis michael lui arrache
sa carte bleue des mains et il sort une
nouvelle fois sur le parking
magali retourne à l'accueil dé à son
ordinateur et 20 minutes plus tard
michael rentre dans l'hôtel cette fois
il est beaucoup plus calme il va voir
magali et lui demande de venir l'aider
parce qu'il a un problème avec sa
voiture
sauf que souvenez vous la voiture avec
laquelle il est arrivé n'est plus sur le
parking de l'hôtel
elle comprend donc que le mec inventent
des trucs pour essayer de la faire
sortir sur le parking dans quel but
elle en sait rien mais elle sait que ça
cache un truc magali
une nouvelle fois et une nouvelle fois
mickaël retourne sur le parking de
l'hôtel
elle est seule dans cet hôtel il est
tard et un mec est clairement menaçant
elle se démerde depuis un moment pour
refuser toutes les demandes du gars mais
elles sont qu'à un moment où l'autre il
va péter un câble elle retourne sur son
ordinateur et elle voit que michael
n'est plus sur le parquet et d'ailleurs
elle voit que michael n'est plus nulle
part
et puis sur la caméra du parking elle
voit un autre véhicule que la
camionnette qu'elle a vu arriver plus
tôt immédiatement elle appelle un des
hôtels aux alentours et lui donne la
plaque d'immatriculation du véhicule en
question et lui demande si cet hôtel là
a déjà enregistré ce véhicule la réponse
est non
elle a les yeux rivés sur la caméra de
surveillance à tel point qu'elle se rend
pas compte que michael est de retour
dans le rôle elle lève la tête et une
fois de plus et lui explique qu'il doit
soit allé dans sa chambre soit quitter
les lieux et là mickaël lui hurle dessus
il lui dit tu dois sortir dehors avec
moi maintenant et m'aider et d'un coup
mickaël sprint au loin sur le parking et
disparaît et du champ de vision de
magali et des caméras de surveillance
magali elle est choquée et il lui reste
dix minutes avant l'arrivée de la
prochaine employés celle qui va prendre
le relais à la réception c'est les dix
minutes les plus longues de sa vie ses
dix minutes pendant lesquelles elle
pense que michael va revenir et cette
fois d'en arriver aux mains eva la
kidnapper de force
heureusement ce n'est jamais arrivé elle
explique ce qui s'est passé à sa
collègue qui risquent de croiser michael
et elles vont toutes les de verrouiller
les portes d'entrée du hall avec un
panneau expliquant que si les clients
veulent rentrer à l'intérieur il faut
appeler la réception et elle rentre chez
elle en sûreté le lendemain elle appelle
ses bosses et ses boss nous explique que
michael n'est jamais revenue dans sa
chambre prendre ces sacs
et oui souvenez vous ils étaient venus
avec des sacs qu'il a déposée dans sa
chambre un mois plus tard magali est de
nouveau à la réception sauf que cette
fois il ya des collègues dans l'hôtel
elle n'est pas seule et qui franchit la
porte d'entrée du hall michael michael
vient la voir et lui demande des
nouvelles à propos des affaires qu'il a
laissé dans sa chambre un mois plus tôt
et il lui demande aussi s'il peut
réserver une chambre elle garde son sang
froid lui explique un employé va lui
adresser à faire mais qu'en revanche et
n'a plus droit d'entrer dans cette
propriété autre chose que magali
remarque c'est que cette fois il est
arrivé à l'hôtel en suv ce qui
correspond ni à la camionnette qu'elle
avait vu un mois plus tôt ni
deuxième véhicule qu'elle avait vu un
mois plus tôt rodez sur le parking mais
qu'elle récupère donc cette affaire et
120 mais après qu'il soit parti magali
elle réalise un truc il l'a appelé par
son prénom
alors au début elle s'est dit bah c'est
normal j'ai un badge et mon prénom est
marqué dessus sauf que ce jour là elle
avait oublié de match en match
michael se souvenait de son prénom un
mois après sa première apparition dans
l'hôtel elle en a donc conclu que
c'était bel et bien un gars creepy qu'il
a ciblé qu'il a probablement vu au loin
à la réception et qui ce soir là lui
voulait du mal mais n'a pas osé passer à
l'acte magali elle n'a plus jamais
travailler seul le soir à l'hôtel sans
la présence de son petit ami qui la
conduisait jusqu'à l'autel et qui
restait avec n
la durée de son service où elle se
retrouver seul dans l'hôtel voilà
messieurs dames maintenant c'est simple
dès que gérer deux nuits dans un endroit
les employés je leur ferai des sourires
je redis aujourd'hui tu veux un café
frérot tout va bien du coup je réécris
pis ils appelleront les flics fait chier
j'espère que ces trois histoires vous en
plus je crois que c'était un vrai droit
plutôt long aujourd'hui habituellement
vous m'en voulais parce qu'ils sont trop
courts écouter aujourd'hui vous devriez
être rassasié en terme d'histoire
d'horreur passé une merveilleuse soirée
et une délicieuse nuit à tr 10
[Musique]